ils viennent du sud ils ont fui les
territoires occupés par les russes
celle-là arrives tu à peine
on a l'impression d'être dans un autre
monde dès qu'on est arrivés on a tout de
suite compris qu'on était dans un pays
libre et puis c'est propre là-bas tout
est tellement salée laissée à l'abandon
il ya des soldats russes par
ces familles viennent de traverser ce
que les russes appellent des passages de
filtration des voyages qui peuvent durer
des jours entiers l'attend dans les
voitures ou les bus les nuits à la belle
étoile et enfin nos merveilleux soldats
nous ont accueillis on les a embrassés
on était en larmes elles ne veulent pas
que leurs visages soient filmés de peur
qu'il arrive quelque chose à leurs
proches restés derrière elles ont décidé
de partir parce que l'armée ukrainienne
le leur demandait ils nous ont dit aidez
nous à continuer le combat évacué avec
vos enfants de toute façon nos enfants
allaient à l'école ukrainienne et
maintenant les russes établissent leur
école là bas avec leur programme et on
n'en veut pas
la plupart de déplacés arrive de kherson
ceux de marioupol plus rares peuvent
solliciter l'aide de leurs
administrations locales
la mairie en exil de la ville portuaire
décimé par la guerre installé une
dizaine de centres comme celui ci à
travers le pays
je ne ressens plus rien à propos des
russes je me sens en forme et la colère
aussi je suppose parce qu'on n'a plus
rien des
plaignants
à 95% marioupol est en ruine les gens
qui ont vécu cette tragédie ceux qui ont
perdu des proches sont extrêmement
affectés psychologiquement jacques
cravache contre x au stade ils ont
besoin de beaucoup de temps de soutien
de thérapie
du temps pour les adultes du
divertissement ont les plus jeunes
et l'espace d'un court dans la guerre
disparaître est presque des yeux des
ondes